clovis casali vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial à kiev bonjour clovis on sent
une grande fébrilité dans la capitale
ukrainienne
fébrilité et craintes sont les deux mots
ici dans la capitale ukrainienne on est
dans le centre-ville un peu à l'écart de
meydan très peu de monde dans les rues
les restaurants les boutiques sont
toutes fermées mais je peux vous dire
regarder derrière moi défilent plus de
200 m sans discontinuer depuis tout à
l'heure des files de voitures qui
attendent devant une seule station
service pour obtenir de l'essence
certains d'entre eux vont quitter kiev
pour essayer d'aller plus vers l'ouest
plus en sécurité et d'autres ont décidé
de rester ici nous avons pu parler avec
des ukrainiens certains sont même venus
à pied avec des jerricanes au kazoo car
ils craignent qu'il ait des ruptures de
stock plus tard les ukrainiens qui nous
avons parlé nous disent eh bien qu'il ne
faut pas paniquer mais que c'est très
compliqué au vu des nouvelles qu'ils ont
de leurs amis dans l'est du pays ou dans
d'autres parties de l'ukraine nous avons
parlé notamment avec un ukrainien qui
fait partie des forces d'autodéfense ces
réservistes et volontaires qui sont
mobilisables en cas d' attaque sur kiev
et cet homme du nom de timothée nous
disait qu'il ne faut pas paniquer qu'il
est prêt à aider comme il le peut donc
un peu de d'inquiétude bien sûr ici de
la crainte de la peur c'est très calme
on a entendu des détonations
ce matin plusieurs détonations dès
l'aube puis il y a eu des détonations
selon des témoignages aux alentours de
kiev à 20 30 km ces derniers temps et
donc beaucoup d'inquiétude ici à kiev
c'est calme pour l'instant mais il ya
des énormes embouteillages à la sortie
de la ville et ce depuis ce matin j'ai
parlé notamment avec une ukrainienne
aussi qui a essayé de fuir avec sa
famille pour mettre sa famille en
sécurité et vu le monde a dû revenir
dans kiev et qui va essayer plutard
clovis on l'a entendu le président
hélène ski qui a repris la parole ce
matin il a appelé une nouvelle fois à la
mobilisation générale il tente aussi de
rassurer la population il a quel image
en ukraine cet ancien comédien
aujourd'hui chef de guerre est ce que la
population lui fais confiance
c'est un personnage atypique sa cote de
popularité était très haute ces derniers
mois elle s'est un petit peu érodés au
fil du temps mais aujourd'hui les
ukrainiens sont unis c'est une nation
ils doivent être unis derrière leur
président ils disent qu'ils ont
confiance en leur président mais aussi
ont leurs troupes nous avons vu des des
blindés ukrainien passé il y à quelques
minutes et bien je peux vous dire que
les voitures klaxonnaient les féliciter
et les encourager
on a aussi vu depuis l'hôtel quelques
chars et des blindés déployés dans la
capitale quadrillée kiev car la crainte
c'est forcément que les forces russes
viennent jusqu'à kiev ça c'est une
inquiétude des gens et je peux vous dire
qu'il ya des gens qui ont fui j'avais le
témoignage d'un collègue qui me disait
que ce matin il s'est réveillé et que le
personnel de l'hôtel lui a dit il va
falloir que tu cherches une autre
chambre car on ferme les employés ne
viennent plus les employés quittent les
lieux et donc forcément un peu de
crainte j'ai aussi parlé avec un
ukrainien qui étaient là tout à l'heure
avec un jerrycan qui était venu faire
des réserves qui me disait que fait
l'ouest l'ouest savaient tout le monde
savait que vale vladimir poutine allait
attaquer le p on ne pensait pas bien sûr
que ça allait arriver si vite si tôt
durant la nuit vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit eh bien ils demandent de l'aide et
le président azzedine ski ce personnage
à aux commandes depuis quelques temps
qui est un personnage atypique pas issus
du monde politique eh bien il demande de
l'aide il demande la création d'une
coalition anti poutine si vous voulez
des pays comme les etats unis la france
la grande bretagne l'allemagne et bien
d'autres qui pourraient faire pression
sur vladimir poutine pour arrêter ces
opérations avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
on ne voit pas comment pour l'instant
puisque la france
pour leurs écarte toute intervention
militaire nous serons sans faiblesse a
dit emmanuel macron mais il n'a rien dit
de concret finalement le président à
part ces menaces de sanctions les
ukrainiens on l'a compris dans
dans ce que vous disiez attendre plus de
la part des occidentaux de la part des
européens ils attendent une intervention
militaire
difficile à dire s'ils attendent une
intervention militaire en tout cas ils
espèrent que les opérations vont cesser
les ukrainiens certains ne croient même
pas ce qui se passe certains ici 10
celle que de la propagande des deux
côtés on peux pas croire qu'il y ait de
telles opérations contre l'ukraine intel
envahissement de la part de la russie
mais forte de on est obligé de constater
que les forces ukrainiennes sont les
forces russes sont entrés en ukraine en
tout cas les ukrainiens à qui nous parle
on souhaite qu'une seule chose la paix
mais ils nous disent aussi que si guerre
il ya il semble bien que ce soit le cas
ils sont prêts à prendre les armes et
encore une fois ici à kiev la crainte
aussi et bien ce soit c'est que les
troupes russes cherchent à rentrer avec
des troupes terrestres ici dans la
capitale ukrainienne merci beaucoup
clovis casali envoyé spécial france 24 à
kiev